Okay, so let's talk a little bit about
Otto's beautiful drawing. So these are the five Wellville cities.
Esther: Communities.
Kara: Communities.
Esther: Health, not "healthcare"
Esther: Communities, not "cities".
Esther: $5 each time.
Kara: Oh god, this is real-time editing all right so tell us a little bit why
these five was the idea five that had lots of things in common or they're each their own sandbox?
Esther: So it it originally began in 2013. I talked to Peter Diamandis and I had been
on the judging panel for the X the
healthcare XPrize which ended up not
happening and the idea was take a
population of covered lives of an
insurance company apply some
intervention and do the financial model
and see who would win for a bunch of
reasons didn't happen and I asked Peter
would you mind if I just kind of lightly
said this is kind of like an X Prize for
health as opposed to care and the idea
was five communities five places
five million if we could get it and five
years
oh and five metrics very clever hmm and
I thought somebody should do this I was
gonna give a talk saying somebody should
do this well so I gave a talk said I
would do it and then I had to figure out
how I will make this very brief but as I
was exploring brainstorming trying to
figure out what this all was there was a
guy who showed up in you know better
dress than I was or most of my friends
who asked so how are you gonna fund this
what are you gonna measure how are you
going to pick the communities all these
awkward questions and if you didn't go
away I have lunch with him and he became
our CEO he brought in Jeff don't lend so
we decided well Rick's a very orderly
guy so we spent a fair amount of time
thinking about all these questions and
finally I said you know let's let's just
find some communities so then we created
this amazing long application form you
had to be under a hundred thousand
people you had to be geographically
self-contained so the idea was whatever
happened in the community would
reverberate within the community rather
than getting dissipated out so it's not
like one of these neighborhood programs
but you never know
they don't have lunch together they go
have lunch the next neighborhood over
where they work or something and third
you need to have some kind of multi
stakeholder coalition there needed to be
some body that was applying that was
already trying to do something with the
community's health so it wasn't we're
gonna find five communities and a nice
white lady's gonna show up and tell you
how to live it was much more we're going
to give you coaching to do what it is
that you want to do but we'll help you
do it smarter will help you find funding
but we're not going to give you money
and we're not going to charge you not
really it's it's sort of in situ I think
of it more as an executive coach or a
gym coach you know we will tell you
about the new gym equipment will advise
you which gym might be good but you're
the one who has to get up at 5:30 and
it's your body so yeah the community has
to own it and they have to they have to
go to the gym on the other hand it's
it's theirs you know and we don't give
them fish we don't teach them how to
fish we help them build their own
fishing schools